we have research production team left
big shoes to step into so well I hope
I'll make it okay so this is so the
question I'm going to talk about is kind
of stemmed from a learning theoretic
motivation what I'm actually going to
talk in the beginning of the of this
talk about the game theoretic aspect so
let's begin with something something
simple that we all know about pretty
simple zero-sum games so I guess I don't
have to say anything about zero-sum
games in this audience but in any case
so what zero-sum game yeah we have N by
n matrix it's a it's a square just for
simplicity we have the role player we
have the column player the rows
represent the strategies for the role
player the columns for the column player
okay
and once the the peak actions I J so
this entry this IJ entry denotes the
loss incurred by the by the role player
which is the profit of the column player
okay so the minimizing player is the
role player okay and our central object
in a zero-sum games is the well-known
von Neumann minimax phenomena
equilibrium which is just the minimum
over all mixed strategies over all
distributions on the rows of the maximum
on of over distributions of the columns
over the columns of the expectation of
the loss when they both play these mixed
strategies these according to these
distributions okay so this is very well
known of course and the kind of
questions I will discuss today is the
what is the time what is the
computational time required to compute
this distinct okay or to approximate it
and especially when the size of the
matrix is extremely large
okay think exponential in some
we'll get to that later okay so what's
the time and what and what about
efficient strategies algorithms for the
player okay so what's the history of
course this is oh yeah very well studied
extremely well studied problem was some
history about it so it's you know it
goes back to the 20s to the 40s so one
nice algorithm suggested suggested in
the late forties by brown is a
fictitious play and this is a very
simple algorithm the players just follow
their best response to the empirical
distribution to the histogram of pass of
it of their opponent past plays okay so
for example they start with something
completely arbitrary X x1 for this one
y1 for this guy and at the next round
this guy will play just the minimizing
strategy X in response to the Y of the
previous step and the sender and
similarly for the conveyor and so on and
so forth in the third step they will
just minimize 1/2 of the loss in their
first round in half of the loss of the
second round minimize over X ok so it's
just big this is the best response ok so
what do what people proved about it so
Julia Robbins and in 51 proved that it
converges to minimax in the limit if if
they will play forever like this they
will converge to their meat to Devon
line line minimax recently it was shown
that while this converges it might need
a large number of iterations exponential
in the size of the matrix okay so this
is done by a Brant and co-authors in
2010 and actually recently it has been
proven by the scalar case and pan that
the convergence rate is exponential so
so this is the T is the number of rounds
could the convergence rate itself is
exponential not only with the number of
iteration is exponential but the
convergence rate is exponential and this
actually yep
so this is the so this is the the the
decay of the air of the error has tea
groves so you can compute the solve for
epsilon if you like but okay this
answers your question okay
and this actually refutes a well-known
conjecture from the late 50s by Colleen
okay so this is an historic kind of
slide ok can we do better than this
exponential time so of course we can it
is well known since the 70s that this
problem is equivalent to LP and elfies
LP is solvable in polynomial time
ok so Brown didn't know about it but
today we know about it so of course it's
fully time solvable and actually the
state of the art is a linear time
algorithm so we gorya this and catch e
on this is the same question that proved
that LP is falling on poly time solvable
I came up with an algorithm that runs in
linear time linear in N and this is and
she also showed that this is tight and
actually the result can be simplified
and framed as they or may be an
alternative algorithm will give the same
running time was shown by finding
shoppearh in a very very well-known
paper from the net from 99 which I will
elaborate on in a minute and note that
this is a sub linear time algorithm ok
so this is this n linear in n but it's
sub linear in the input size right so
this is a non-trivial result and this a
result by the way was generalized by
Larson it are two more general minimax
problems I will mention in in passing
that they are more recent result from
their very recent years about a
convergence rate that looks like poly n
over T so this is an improved
convergence rate in terms of T all of
these all of these results are convert
the rate of convergence is 1 over root e
so this is better in terms of T but my
focus in this talk will be
on the dependence on n okay so forget
about they think about constant
approximation to the minimax and we will
only care about the dependence on the
size on a matrix okay by the way stopped
me at any time for questions yes yeah
that's one way to interpret it yeah you
don't have to read the entire matrix
exactly surprising I guess okay
no questions okay so let me tell you a
few words about this Freudian Shapira
approach which is based on regret
minimization or online learning as we
call it these days
and in this approach both the players
just use online learning algorithms
front-end Shapiro used the
multiplicative wage which I am sure that
by now all all of the audience is
familiar with this algorithm and what
kind of happens here so they are
minimizing the regret so each player is
minimizing it is regret regardless of
what the other players are doing okay I
will define everything a bit more
precisely later but they regret of a
multiplicative which decays like this
there it has a dependence on log and in
there is a regret so we need log n over
epsilon squared iterations to converge
to epsilon regret it can be implemented
in linear time per round okay so we need
an overall we need n over epsilon
squared time for epsilon approximation
of the game okay so I'm of course
skipping few details here but this is
the main picture okay this gives a
linear time algorithm okay
what's the problem with this I want you
to think about games that are huge as I
said before and games that we often
encounter in computer science are
exponentially large so just you know
kind of prototypical examples think
about the x-axis day AK is the action
set of the of the Rope layer it's all of
the SD paths in some graph okay so this
is an exponent
Cosette exponentially site setting the
number of nodes or maybe the set of all
permutations of n items or maybe subsets
of n items okay and while all of these
examples are exponentially large we
still can compute best responses back to
this fictitious play algorithm we can
steal back a compute best responses or
optimize over the action set efficiently
right
and when I say efficiently I mean poly
log n so log n is something that I think
about is polynomial and we are
polynomial in this okay so this leads to
the following question can we do better
if we assume that we know how to do best
responses efficiently
okay so assume that best response can be
computed efficiently poly log n time we
have a black box Oracle for each player
in the game that computes the best
response okay and this is kind of a
structural assumption on the matrix
without explicitly defining structure
okay so the structure here is in please
left implicit can we do something better
okay can we do can we compute solve
efficiently zero-sum games computer
approximate the von Neumann minimax or
more generally can we fix this sorry
more specifically can we fix this a gate
minimization approach okay for example
can we stick to this login over T root
login over T regrets while doing only
constant computation per round okay and
then this will lead us to something like
look like this poly log n time for
approximation can we fix this online
learning approach okay so this is kind
of the main question I will talk about
any quite any questions about this
before I go a bit into details okay so
let me define the regret minimization
question or the only learning question
you've seen this kind of slide a few
times so I'll do it very quickly so what
is the only learning setting in from the
perspective of the Rope layer okay I'm
focusing on their own player now so he
has to play in rounds 44 capital T
rounds in each round he has to pick one
action or an expert in the owner
learning terminology XT the adversary
which is the opponent now their column
player picks YT and the role player
suffers a loss which is L X T YT I will
just denote it by L T of X T because we
are only focusing on the row player now
okay so the column player is made the
kind of his choices are made implicit
and the usual goal is to minimize the
regret the difference between our he's
lost their own their loss and the best
he could have obtained using a fixed
action okay the best one and just for
runtime purposes I'm assuming a value
access to the matrix okay so we have if
you like an oracle value oracle that
just gives me this loss in constant time
okay this is for for run time this is
kind of the computational model okay on
top of this standard model I'm going to
assume a best response overkill as I
just said which is a formally it's is a
procedure that accepts as input a subset
of columns okay of the actions of the
opponent and emits the best response to
those to that set of actions okay so
just the minimizing action of this sum
of the sum of losses of overall
reactions in the set s the opponent's
actions okay so in this model I'm going
to ask whether we can learn efficiently
okay can we get for example regret lower
than some constant let's say one quarter
in poly log n time okay if the answer is
affirmative we can also solve games
efficiently in in the in the when when
we have optimization or best response
Oracle's
okay make sense
Paulo again a so for EM I mean overall
so the iOS the algorithm is going to run
for some time some capital T rounds I
leave it unspecified but the overall
computation will be imported again okay
that would imply a poly log and
solvability of zero-sum games okay I
just mentioned a few our kind of
motivation for this problem more broadly
in very quickly and our motivation was
we asked the following bait I think very
basic question in learning theory is
there a generic and efficient reduction
of online learning to adopting ization
if we know how to do optimization can we
do efficiently can we do online learning
efficiently and this is kind of seeking
for an analogue of the step of the
fundamental theorem of statistical
learning in the statistical case okay in
the case of statistical learning if we
know how to optimize we can also learn
efficiently because in the finite case
when the hypothesis class is finite
which is the case I'm discussing we have
a logarithmic dependence on the number
of examples required for learning and so
if we know up to optimize over them
efficiently we can also learn in the
statistical sense so this is the
analogous question to the online
learning domain okay so this is this was
our question and this of course if this
question for example is a positive
answer then of course and of course we
get a generic way of you know converting
offline to online algorithms and many
many many specialized algorithms for
many settings that were considered in
the online learning literature are kind
of redundant or you know special cases
of so it would be nice to understand
this question
and in fact they you know the standard
frameworks in online learning are based
on reductions to optimization but
require further assumptions and there
are numerous examples I want to go into
details but this is kind of you know
this is what we do in on and learning we
reduce a problem to the offline problems
of the offline and show how to convert
it to an online algorithm okay so that's
about the learning theoretic aspect let
me show you the results
so is it obvious that it's either way is
it obvious that it's Polly Polly Logan
is possible or the other way right so
you need something else yeah yeah but
you know you can you have an
optimization order that can produce a
best response to whatever you like in
constant time almost constant time yeah
yes what's the right thing I I think
about it as an optimization auto that
solves a you know huge linear program in
very quickly that is there is an
implicit you know implicit 16th
representation of this program that you
can feed it feed it to it and it will
solve it okay and the answer is the
question is whether this kind of
powerful Oracle which we happen to have
in many applications translate into an
efficient or a algorithm for games
here's some s yeah so basically this is
a simplified simplified version of the
Oracle think about you feed it a
distribution over columns it's a it's a
multi set or yeah you can think about it
as a multi set so they're the
representation of the distribution is
just the list of atoms okay do you you
can feel it any empirical distribution
over columns you just feed it a list of
you know like in think about fictitious
plane you just you saw what what your
opponent did in the past you can feed it
like a short list of items and it gives
you the best response okay I don't think
so I mean and still it would it give you
a linear time sub linear time algorithm
okay and still it won't give you an
efficient algorithm right no okay so
okay okay I got your comment any more
questions before I get into results
so tea you get to pick tea because you
want to solve a game okay I want to
solve a game I would be to pick the tea
that suits me okay
as long as I eventually solve it okay
let me get to the results can we do that
so the answer the short answer is no
unfortunately no so the lower bounds
applies tools solving games okay so if
any algorithm not not necessarily linear
sorry online learning algorithm any
algorithm that solves the game ending
zero-sum game to within epsilon equals
1/4 accuracy has to run in run in time
routine at least root n okay and this
also implies sorry there is a root
missing here the same but the same lower
bound for the only learning problem okay
if we could do only learning in x less
than root n then we could also solve
games in less than root N and this is
what can show it is impossible to be
impossible okay however an interesting I
think to me a result is that this is
tight so we can we can actually achieve
this root and this improvement to
routine there exists an online learning
algorithm that minimizes regret bring
the average regret to epsilon in time
root n over epsilon squared and this is
of course tight in in light of the lower
bound okay and this is give the
quadratic improvement with respect to
the setting without oracle's and of
course so this is the corollary of this
of this result is that we can also solve
games and by n zero-sum games in root n
time and this is tight so we get here a
for fruit of the input size our
dependence in the is on the forefoot of
the input
so let me give few words about how much
time do I have not too much right five
minutes okay so I will just give a
glimpse of how we prove it I think the
kind of the over picture is nice so the
lower bound is based on a reduction from
local search problems and I will just
you know show you a nice result from
that we use in the lower bound from the
80s by a nice result by aldose and I'll
just try to investigated the the
complexity of local search problems over
the hypercube with n vertices and he
kind of constructed a distribution over
functions on this I per cube that have
only a single local minimum and it will
be hard to find this minimum by a local
search okay so I will give a few details
so how does first how does this
distribution look like so he just picked
a vertices at random from the from this
cube and started a random walk from this
vertex a simple random walk okay and the
function this induces a function over
the hypercube by taking f function of I
to be the heating time to the vertex I
okay so for example I could have pick
this this vertex the value of this
vertex is now zero because this is the
starting vertex and now the random walks
goes here so this is labeled by 1 by 2
by 3 and so on
ok this covers the entire hypercube and
it's easy to quote it's very easy to see
that each such such a function has a
single local minimum as required by
aldose because there on the walk start
from some and any other other vertex we
must have reached it from somewhere
right so there is only one local minimum
which is where this zero which is a
global minimum and what is the number of
queries required to to find this minimum
so this is kind of the the question that
I'll just asked how many how much
queries to the function do I have to
issue in order to find this minimum so
there is a simple very classic algorithm
that does this in the root end time
based on sampling you
just query their sample at random
routine vertices and optimize from find
the minimum of the function of these
vertices and optimize from there okay I
don't have to I don't have time to get
into details but this is a very classic
that simple in a classic algorithm whose
analysis is two lines and I'll deuce and
this is not by Aldous I'll just actually
prove that this is the best possible
this is like this simple algorithm is
tight okay the the the proof is very non
not simple and non-trivial okay but
since Aldous has done such impressive
work we can use it and our hardness
results for learning in games builds on
reduction from this problem so again in
to in few words we take a function whose
minimum we would like to find and we
will we will build a zero-sum game in a
very simple way just a comparison matrix
of this sorting matrix of this function
and we will hide its equilibrium in one
of the in one of the corners here okay
and and we will argue that if the
algorithm has solved this game then you
can also ears also found the minimum of
the function okay so the basically the
one the thing I have to show you is that
F or I Oracle access to F also gives us
value and optimization Oracle's for this
game for our model okay I'm not going to
show you but this is not too hard the
reduction is not too complicated and one
slide on the upper bound I have one
minute okay how do we achieve this
improvement in the four to root M so the
idea the basic very basic idea is to
reduce the number of experts number of
actions from n to root n okay this is
what will give us the result and how do
we do that so the way to think about it
I think is to interpolate between two
extreme cases the first case is that
there are very few leaders in the online
game what is the leader it's an expert
that or an action that has been the best
up until some point in time okay that's
a leader the leading action
in some time if there are very few
leaders throughout the game throughout
the online learning game then the
optimization Oracle is very useful right
we can immediately identify those
leaders there are a few of them so we
can follow them in some way okay so this
case is indeed easy this optimization
Oracle just gives us these leaders in
very quickly and the other extreme the
leader keeps changing okay so there are
a lot of leaders there are n experts and
all of them are leaders in some point
okay so we have to follow a lot of a lot
of experts a lot of leaders throughout
the game but then we can again use the
sampling trick from this locus from
analog boosts to this to the local
search problems we can sample route and
experts at random in the beginning of
time and you know once we sample N and
experts one of them we like is likely to
be in the root and finalists in the game
what is the finalist is a expert that
has been so the finalist is the best
expert overall the second final is that
the second one is the best is the best
expert before this this best expert has
been become the expert a the final
leader and so on okay so the root and
finalist those that have been good
almost throughout the entire game ok and
the whole idea is to interpolate between
those two cases both of them are very
easy but the interpolation is kind of
challenging and I will not get into
details but I will just say that the
most difficult part is in this final
stage where we know that we sampled one
good action that brought us almost till
the end of time and now we just have to
figure out what to do in this last last
part of the game when we know that there
are very few leaders in involved here ok
so this is kind of the most challenging
part and I don't have time to get into
details but eventually the algorithms
look like this we kind of follow the
leaders we can accuse them in in in
accuse and will give more
more significance to the one to the
recent ones okay so we have a queue that
holds only the recent leader the queue
that will hold only the two recent
leader and so on so in effect we are
giving the the recent leader is more
effect okay and for this algorithm we
can prove that with high probability our
delegate will be bounded by the fourth
root of M okay so let me conclude the
bottom line here is that efficient
optimization or best response in games
does not imply efficient online learning
unfortunately but is that it does help
it does help quadratically reduces the
time and quadratically and there are two
me intriguing connections to local
search problems that I think they are
very interesting and there are many
questions left open here
what about positive results there are
some nice positive results that was very
recently this year and and of course we
have to assume an additional assumptions
but this is something that we would like
to you know this is a problem we would
like to solve under some assumptions
what our natural assumptions under which
we can give actual efficient algorithms
and a nice probable Oracle complexity so
I talked about running time but Oracle
complexity complexity is kind of open
Oracle complexity of this optimization
Oracle and approximate optimization and
so on so forth many interesting
questions so that's it thank you
yes do you I mean they could move is
actually the just equilibrium is its
location is so it's not deterministic at
all no so because it the function with
which we reduce from is random okay so
it's location is also random its
location kind of corresponds to the
location of the minimum of the function
that we reduce from if the value of the
equilibrium or D so no it's not it's not
deterministic of course otherwise we
could have known it's out of time right
just yeah so it has to be random yeah
and it is also the value is is not
deterministic
so we'll take this two minutes I have a
question